first up squad goals you know it can be
so hard for today's politicians to
connect with Millennials especially for
Machiavelli and Mamaw Hillary Clinton as
why she that's why she took two young
people's social network snapchat this
week to post a video of her with some
lady pals along with the very millennial
caption this squad everyone oh yes
indeed
my squadron is on fleek ha ha stay on
target
okay everyone pick a color from the
color wheel and let's make those tops
happen comedians what are this squads
goals Jenni beating osteoporosis yes
Chris Garcia green-lighting 1/4 Bridget
Jones movie yeah what's the squad's goal
Chris to pound Chardonnay do tons of
blow and stay up till 4:00 I am sticking
each other's period
vagina work Jordan yeah there ain't no
eggs in that basket